und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend das
eine dreier-koalition keine leichte
Sache ist war klar aber jetzt sind sie
in der Ampel schon bei regelrechten
Ultimaten angekommen
einsichtlich genervter SPD-Fraktionschef
Mützenich erklärt der FDP sie habe jetzt
24 Stunden Zeit zumindest der ersten
Lesung des heizungsgesetzes im Bundestag
zuzustimmen was ja nur so viel heißt als
dass der am Kabinett gemeinsam
beschlossene Gesetzentwurf ins Parlament
eingebracht wird und dann in die
Ausschüsse geht um dort diskutiert und
verändert zu werden soweit der übliche
Gang aber selbst sehen will die FDP
jetzt nicht mehr mitgehen das ganze
Gesetz passt ihr nicht womit die
Koalition bei diesem Thema eigentlich
zurück auf losgehen müsste Dritter
Buchholz berichtet
der Streit innerhalb der Ampel kreist
aktuell vor allem um diese eine Frage
wann debattiert der Bundestag das
Gebäude Energiegesetz in dieser Woche
sollte es losgehen eigentlich der
SPD-Fraktionschef gibt sich genervt und
drängt öffentlich den eigenen
Koalitionspartner die FDP hat jetzt noch
24 Stunden Zeit der ersten Lesung des
Gesetzes zuzustimmen und wir haben
genügend Parlamentarierinnen und
Parlamentarier in allen Fraktionen die
aus diesem Gesetz etwas Besseres machen
können die FDP fast das als ein
Ultimatum auf und stellt klar sie wollen
das Gesetz so nicht eine Kritik zu
starke Fokussierung auf die Wärmepumpe
es sind ungewöhnlich harsche Töne
kosmetische Veränderungen werden nichts
bringen und das Gesetz muss insgesamt
verändert werden das ist eine so große
Baustelle dass ich mir nicht vorstellen
kann dass wir in dieser Sitzungswoche
geschweige denn vor der Sommerpause da
ein erzielen können erst kürzlich
schickte die FDP einen umfänglichen
Fragenkatalog an die Verantwortlichen
Ministerien Beratungsbedarf oder
politisches Kalkül der Bundeskanzler
sagt öffentlich heute nichts dazu
ausrichten lässt er auch mit
Schnelligkeit müsste diskutiert werden
dem Wirtschaftsminister selbst scheint
der Ampel Streit die Laune nicht zu
verderben er erinnert die Liberalen an
Vertragstreue und bemüht sich den Druck
rauszunehmen
es ist ja kein Geheimnis dass die
Bundesregierung noch in der
Meinungsfindung ist insofern ist es auch
okay wenn es noch Fragen zu klären gibt
ich bin optimistisch dass wir das vor
den Sommerferien verabschieden werden
und der Bundestag seine gute Arbeit
daran tun wird Habeck will am Zeitplan
festhalten ungeachtet der Turbulenzen in
seinem Ministerium die Entlassung des
zuständigen energiestaatssekretärs
reichen hatte das Problem noch
verschärft dieser wird nun ersetzt durch
Philipp nimmermann bisher Staatssekretär
im hessischen Wirtschaftsministerium
frischer Wind gleich neues Tempo DIE
LINKE fordert aber grundlegendes
Umdenken beim Umbau der Wärmeversorgung
es handelt sich ja um ziemliches Paket
was offensichtlich unter hohen Zeitdruck
entwickelt wurde und das wie gesagt
nutzt tatsächlich an dieser Stelle
niemand man kann nur noch mal sagen
solange der soziale Schutz nicht klar
also das nicht funktioniert und das
nicht ausreichend debattiert wurde wird
dieses Gesetz auch keine Akzeptanz
finden die 24 Stunden laufen morgen früh
ab dann wird entschieden ob sich das
Parlament in dieser Woche mit dem
Gesetzesentwurf befassen wird Ausgang
offen
und darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem
stellvertretenden
fDP-Fraktionschef Lukas Köhler guten
Abend Herr Köhler einen wunderschönen
guten Abend wir haben es gesehen der
Fraktionschef der Kanzlerpartei Herr
Mütze nicht ist sichtlich genervt wie
sieht es denn aus werden sie bis Ablauf
dieser 24 Stunden noch irgendwie zu
Porto kommen na ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das genervtsein von
einem Fraktionsvorsitzenden in
irgendeiner Weise Einfluss auf die
Entscheidung und die
Entscheidungsfindung bei uns in der
Fraktion oder auch in der Regierung hat
ist ja völlig in Ordnung dass das Rolf
Mütze nicht da Probleme sieht das kann
er gerne noch mal mit Christian dürr
unserem Fraktionsvorsitzenden besprechen
das ist auch der normale Weg Ultimaten
über die Presse zu stellen weiß ich
nicht ob das sinnvoll ist ergibt sich ja
quasi aus den Zeitabläufen wenn man
jetzt vor der Sommerpause noch Formen
kommen will die Frage ist ja warum die
FDP ist in dem Parlament nicht zutraut
die Änderungen vorzunehmen die Sie sich
wünschen das Gesetz wird hier im
Parlament beraten und das ist auch der
richtige Weg das ist auch genau der Ort
an dem wir dieses Gesetz jetzt noch mal
deutlich besser machen müssen noch mal
quasi vom Kopf auf die Füße stellen
müssen aber das Gesetz hängt ja mit
einer ganzen Reihe von anderen Fragen
zusammen dem der Diskussion die aus dem
Koalitionsausschuss auch alle kommen die
den Klimaschutz betreffen das
Klimaschutzgesetz die wärmeplanung das
Energieeffizienzgesetz da gibt es ganz
viele unterschiedliche Themen die
miteinander zusammenhängen und das
müssen wir auch umsetzen und das soll
ins Parlament eingebracht werden erste
Lesung und die blockieren sie ja erstmal
also eine blockierten Blockade sehe ich
nicht dass meines Wissens nach muss
jedes Gesetz durch die Koalition
gemeinsam beschlossen aufgesetzt werden
und dieser diesem Entschluss das ist ein
ganz normaler vorsagengang haben wir
bisher noch nicht zugestimmt das können
wir auch nicht tun solange nicht andere
Fragen die wesentlich sind geklärt sind
es gab aber mal sowas wie ein
gemeinsamen Kabinettsentwurf absolut es
gibt einen Entwurf aus dem Kabinett der
ist jetzt im Bundestag zugegangen und
der Bundestag das ist ja auch die
höchste
Entscheidungsebene die wir in
Deutschland haben entscheidet jetzt wann
das ganze Gesetz aufgesetzt wird und wie
wir darüber sprechen werden also sie
wollen verzögern das Gesetz wollen wir
nicht verzögern das ist gar nicht das
Ziel wenn die SPD und die Grünen sagen
Mensch die Forderungen die FDP aufstellt
die Punkte und Positionen können wir
jetzt umsetzen warum können wir dann
können wir das auch so schnell und den
schnellste Form durchsetzen ich mache da
allerdings Fragezeichen dran weil in dem
Gesetz noch einiges geändert werden muss
dann hätten wir müssen sie ja auch auf
ein zwei Punkte nennen können wo sie
sagen liebe Leute von den Grünen oder
von der SPD wenn das so kommt dann sind
dabei also die SPD macht das ja zum
Beispiel mehr Mieterschutz und über
diese Altersgrenze noch mal reden nennt
da ja ein zwei konkrete Punkte und von
der FDP kommen aber 100 Fragen aber
eigentlich keine konkrete Forderung ich
glaube es gibt ja unterschiedliche
Vorgänge das eine sind die Fragen und es
gibt eine Menge Fragen die
berechterweise gestellt sind und
gestellt werden müssen weil das Gesetz
löst eben Fragen aus wir haben ja in der
Bevölkerung und in der Diskussion
innerhalb der Bevölkerung auch eine
Menge Punkt und Positionen gesehen und
natürlich gibt es bei 177 Seiten
Gesetzestext auch eine Menge fachlicher
Fragen die müssen geklärt werden und
gute Verhandlungen zu führen aber
inhaltlich waren wir bisher sehr klar
und äh haben sehr sehr viele sehr klare
Punkte gemacht unter anderem die
Herausforderung wie wir bei der
technologieoffenheit mit Heizung umgehen
die Frage also wie sind die ähm wir sind
die Möglichkeiten bei Pelletheizung im
Neubau wie geht es mit den Fristen und
der Kopplung an die kommunale
wärmeplanung das könnte man jetzt nicht
nach einer ersten Lesung und den
Ausschüssen wir müssen eine Menge Dinge
klären und wir müssen natürlich auch mit
den
Ministerien sprechen Wissen über die
Fragen sprechen die da sind die
Fachfragen klären und dann müssen wir
die inhaltlichen Verhandlungen in der
Regierung die aus der Regierung zu uns
gekommen sind ins Parlament auch mit dem
Parlament klären zu diesen 100 Fragen
die ja jetzt so die Runde machen zu den
Autoren dieser 100 Fragen gehört auch
ein Bundestagsabgeordneter der sich
gerne auch zur energiepolitischen Fragen
äußert aus ihrer Partei Herr Scheffler
der selber von sich sagte ist Klima
Skeptiker bzw Zitat wird es dann doch
dennoch ein wenig wärmer dann freue ich
mich über die besseren Ernteerträge die
milderen Winter und den besseren Weinen
das wirft natürlich die Frage auf ob sie
vielleicht in der FDP grundsätzlich ihre
Haltung zum Thema Klimawandel und
Klimaschutz noch für sich selbst klären
müssen ich weiß nicht ob alte Zitate uns
hier weiterbringen wesentlich ist was
wir im Bundestag eingebracht haben in
den letzten Jahren und jetzt auch gerade
immer wieder an Anträgen stellen und das
ist ganz klar wir wollen die Klimaziele
die das Pariser Abkommen uns vorgibt
einhalten unser Weg ist das hat ja auch
mal ebenhofer auch noch mal sehr schön
gerade betont unser Weg ist der aus
unserer Sicht beste nämlich über den
europäischen Emissionshandel den wollen
wir so schnell wie möglich ausweiten
möglichst auch schon 20-24 Herrn Vogel
mit ihrem FDP am vizeparteichef einen
Vorschlag auf ein Parteitag gemacht der
wurde aber dann sofort von Christian
Lindner kassiert geht nicht das
vorzuziehen also so richtig konkret und
temporeich ist die FDP da in diesem
Thema bisher nicht aufgetreten oder
Christian Lindner hat ja darauf
verwiesen dass der europäische
missionshandel der für 2027
ausgeschrieben wurde dass der nicht
vorgezogen werden kann das ist auch ein
richtiger Punkt das wird im
Europaparlament wäre das extrem
schwierig das umzusetzen ein anderer
Fall liegt ja mit dem Brennstoff
emissionshandelsgesetz vor das haben wir
in Deutschland das ist auch schon so
angelegt dass wir da sehr schnell eine
Mission handelt ausmachen können echt
echten den Vorschlag haben wir zwei Tage
nach dem Parteitag auch noch mal in der
Fraktion beschlossen und meines Wissens
nach ist Christian hat Teil dieser
Fraktion und hat das genauso mit
beschlossen deswegen glaube ich nicht
dass es da einen Unterschied oder in
Essen gibt der Punkt vom Klima Schutz
ist aber wir müssen den so schnell wie
möglich so kosten günstig wie möglich
und so zielgenau wie möglich Einheiten
und das bietet der missionshandel als
leitinstrument für unsere Klimapolitik
deswegen gibt es keine Frage ob die FDP
Klimaschutz machen will es gibt auch
keine Frage daran dass wir die Ziele
einhalten wollen sondern im Gegenteil
das ist ein extrem gutes und valides
Instrument dass wir meiner Meinung nach
auch zum Gebäude Energiegesetz dann
nutzen können wie schnell dann das mit
der FDP dann jetzt doch noch klappt und
wie schnell die Ampelkoalition dann da
in die Gänge kommt Herr Köhler vielen
Dank für das Gespräch vielen herzlichen
Dank
ein anderer Bereich bei dem es nicht so
einfach ist Klimaschutz zu verwirklichen
ist der Tourismus auf dem
Tourismusgipfel in Berlin war das heute
großes Thema Nachhaltigkeit beim Reisen
Billigflieger und Massentourismus sind
ja schon länger in Verruf geraten
andererseits Urlaub da wo es schön ist
nur noch für die die sich ökologisch
korrekte Ferien leisten können wer
umweltbewusst reisen kann und will
findet immerhin ein wachsendes Angebot
auch die Reisebranche ist da im Wandel
Svenja Dohmeier und Shirin alkanak
zeigen das am Beispiel der Ferieninsel
Juist
klimafreundlicher Urlaub geht auf der
Nordseeinsel Juist ganz leicht
Pferdegespanne und Fahrräder Stadtautos
die gestresste urlauberseele
entschleunigt zum Hufgetrappel und
schätzt Natur und Nachhaltigkeit
Erholung autofrei ja viel Natur deshalb
wir haben in Deutschland so viele tolle
Ecken da muss ich nicht unbedingt mit
dem Flugzeug durch die Gegend fliegen
doch Ferienwohnungen und Hotels auf der
klimafreundlichen Insel werden immer
teurer die Immobilienpreise haben sich
in zehn Jahren fast verdoppelt
Hotelbesitzer Stefan Danzer kämpft wie
viele seiner Kollegen mit steigenden
Kosten für Personal Energie und
Lebensmittel Nachhaltigkeit kommt noch
oben drauf wir haben sehr viel Geld
investiert in die energetische Sanierung
des Hauses unter anderem auch die
Dächern neu gedeckt wir haben einige
Blockheizkraftwerke mit der wir unsere
Energie erzeugen und die abwehren eben
hier zur Beheizung nutzen weniger
CO2-Ausstoß lautet auch die politisch
gewollte Marschroute heute Thema auf dem
Tourismusgipfel in Berlin die Branche
sieht die Notwendigkeit von Klimaschutz
intakte Ferienorte sind schließlich ihr
Produkt warnt aber auch für hören Kosten
für die Urlauber
man darf sich da glaube ich nichts
vormachen Nachhaltigkeit wird hinterher
auch im Preis sichtbar sein aber Reisen
ist es eben auch wert also reisen ist
ein höheren preiswert als das wie wir es
in der letzten Zeit vermarktet haben
auch dafür müssen wir wieder kämpfen man
Pfeile aber auch an nachhaltigen
Angeboten für den kleinen Geldbeutel
betonen Reiseanbieter denn das
ökologische Gewissen der Urlauber wächst
zwar schaltet sich in den Ferien dann
allerdings doch meist ab Alltag fällt es
uns leicht den Müll zu trennen den
Fernseher aus dem Standby-Modus
rauszuschalten das ist alles
selbstverständlich die Bundesbürger
haben das auch erkannt im Urlaub sieht
es etwas anders aus da stellen wir eben
fest viele wählen doch nach wie vor das
Flugzeug als anreisemittel und Abreise
Mittel Urlaub wird mehr Wasser
verbraucht es wird auch mehr Fleisch
konsumiert um den Tourismus in
klimafreundliche Bahnen zu lenken will
die Regierung 45 Milliarden Euro für die
Sanierung des streckenetzes investieren
das ist für die Menschen einfach ist
auch mit den öffentlichen Nahverkehr zu
fahren oder mit öffentlichen Verkehr zu
fahren und gleichzeitig bei bezahlbaren
Preisen weil das ist immer auch wichtig
Tourismus lebt davon dass die Menschen
sich leisten können auch daran müssen
wir arbeiten denn was nützt eine
nachhaltige Insel auf der sich am Ende
nur noch wenige einen Urlaub leisten
können
zu dem Thema gibt es nachher im heute
journal Update ein Gespräch mit Jana
Schimke der Vorsitzenden im
Tourismusausschuss des Bundestags
dann blicken wir in die Ukraine das
Kriegsgeschehen ist derzeit schwer
einzuschätzen zumal wenn psychologische
Kriegsführung mit dem Spiel ist so sind
möglicherweise die Ereignisse in der
russischen Grenzregion Belgorod zu
werden von dort werden Kämpfe gemeldet
die Russen sprechen von ukrainischen
Saboteuren die russische Grenzposten
attackieren jetzt sagt man habe damit
nichts zu tun es handelt sich um
Aufständische Russen wohnen eine gewisse
Ironie liegen könnte ähnlich
argumentierte seinerzeit der Kreml als
2014 im Donbass die sogenannten grünen
Männchen auftauchten mit den Moskau
angeblich nichts zu tun hat
der weil in Brüssel heute die
Außenminister und Ministerinnen der EU
bereten vor allem über neue Sanktionen
gegen Russland warum ist dabei Streit
gibt berichtet Florian neu an
kein Lächeln kein Wort für die Kameras
in Brüssel hat petersiato wie so oft
kaum etwas übrig was er heute zu sagen
hat schreibt der ungarische
Außenminister für seine Fans auf
Facebook im Tonfall eines
Widerstandskämpfers wie groß der Druck
auch sein mag wir werden heute nicht
nachgeben es ist ein altbekanntes Drama
dass sie heute auf der Brüsseler Bühne
aufführen Ungarn gegen den Rest diesmal
geht es um das 11 Sanktionspaket gegen
Russland das ein Problem angehen soll
dass der EU Außenbeauftragte so
beschreibt vor den Jumbo wir haben zum
Beispiel unseren Export von europäischen
Autos nach Russland umfasst 80%
verringert und zur selben Zeit stieg der
Export in manche der zentralasiatischen
Nachbarstaaten umfasst 300%
da kann man sich doch gut vorstellen
dass diese Autos von dort weiter
verkauft werden nach Russland oder die
Umgebung von Sanktionen Europa wird seit
langem Handeln Ungarn macht nicht mit
weil es sich an dieser Liste stört
Sponsoren des Krieges so prangert die
Ukraine Firmen an die trotz Krieg noch
Geschäfte mit Russland machen darauf
auch die größte ungarische Bank OTP
solange die Bank auf der Liste stehe
werde Ungarn jede Entscheidung
blockieren droht der Außenminister was
viele andere hier nervt
es ist nicht das erste
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem für Europa in
den letzten 15 Monaten denn es gibt
Länder die Themen verknüpfen die nichts
miteinander zu tun haben
ein Land kann alles blockieren
Sanktionen beschließt Europa nur
einstimmig das ist ein grundsätzliches
Problem sagt die deutsche
Außenministerin wir haben in der
Vergangenheit erlebt dass wenn es eine
Einstimmigkeit im Außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen Bereich braucht
und man eben keine gemeinsame Stimme
findet dass man als weltpolitische
Akteur nicht wirklich vorkommt erstmals
versammelt bärburg heute offiziell eine
Freundesgruppe 12 Staaten die sich für
Mehrheitsentscheidungen in der EU
Außenpolitik einsetzen das Ungarn nicht
dabei ist Ben dürfte es überraschen
überraschender vielleicht dass der
ungarische Außenminister dann doch noch
vor die Kameras tritt und seinen Konter
lanciert die Freundesgruppe des wehos
natürlich werden wir als Mitgliedstaaten
die die Einstimmigkeit bewahren wollen
und damit die Möglichkeit unsere
nationalen Interessen in Brüssel zu
verteidigen natürlich werden wir da eng
zusammenarbeiten
was Europa an diesem Abend also hat zwei
neue Freundesgruppen und weiter keinen
einstimmigen Beschluss zur Umgebung von
Sanktionen
und auch über den Umgang mit Iran wurde
heute in Brüssel gesprochen damit geht
es jetzt bei dir weiter Heinz die EU
verschärft erneut die Sanktionen gegen
Iran nach neuen Hinrichtungen dort die
erweiterten Strafmaßnahmen wegen
anhaltende Verstöße gegen Menschenrechte
richten sich unter anderem gegen eine
Einheit der sogenannten revolutionären
und Verantwortliche der Polizei die EU
forderte Iran erneut auf keine
Todesurteile mehr gegen Demonstrantinnen
und Demonstranten zu verhängen oder zu
vollstrecken
trotz seines deutlichen Wahlsiegs will
der amtierende Ministerpräsident
Griechenlands mit sotakis Neuwahlen das
sagte er in einem Gespräch mit
Staatspräsidentin sakilla Europa nachdem
sie ihm heute dass Mandat zur
Regierungsbildung erteilt hat bei
Neuwahlen kann mit zutakis mit seiner
konservativen Partei Nähe Demokratie auf
eine absolute Mehrheit hoffen dank eines
dann geltenden neuen Wahlrechts
in Bremen haben die Wahlsieger von der
SPD heute mit ihren bisherigen Partnern
Grüne und Linkspartei gesprochen man
kenne sich gut sagte Bürgermeister boven
Schulte von der SPD nun wolle man sehen
ob man auch Zukunftsthemen zusammen
meistern können die SPD hatte zuvor
schon einzeln mit beiden Parteien
gesprochen und auch mit der CDU und
übermorgen will der SPD Landesvorstand
dann entscheiden mit wem über eine
Koalition verhandelt werden soll
wegen Verstößen gegen die europäische
datenschutzgrundverordnung dsgvo hat
eine irische Aufsichtsbehörde gegen den
Facebook Mutterkonzern Meta eine Rekord
Geldstrafe von 1,2 Milliarden Euro
verhängt konkret weil er Nutzerdaten in
die USA weiterleitet zudem forderte die
Behörde Meter auf künftig keine
personenbezogenen Daten von EU-Bürgern
mehr in die USA zu verarbeiten oder zu
speichern Hintergrund des Verfahrens ist
ein seit Jahren laufender Streit wegen
der Übertragung von Daten europäischer
Facebook-Nutzer auf US-Server kündigte
an gegen die Entscheidung in Berufung zu
gehen
diesen Sonntag geht es in der Türkei in
die Stichwahl und damit sind auch die in
Deutschland lebenden Wahlberechtigten
aufgerufen ein zweites Mal an die uns zu
gehen seit Samstag haben die
entsprechenden Wahllokale hier geöffnet
für all jene die auf Wechsel und
demokratische Veränderungen hofften weil
die erste Runde der Präsidentschaftswahl
ja eine Enttäuschung unter den
Deutschtürken Schnitt der autoritäre
Erdogan noch deutlich besser ab als bei
den Wählern in der Türkei und seine
Unterstützer tun viel dafür damit das
auch in der zweiten Runde so bleibt dazu
eine Reportage von Dominik Müller
Russell aus einem Wahllokal in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
Wahlkampfendspurt auf den allerletzten
Mietern direkt vorm Generalkonsulat in
Köln kurz vor den Wahlurnen zwei bei
Türken und Deutsch Türken bekannte AKP
Influenza ziehen in diesen Tagen von
Konsulat zu Konsulat und sorgen dort für
Stimmung sie preisen Recep Tayyip
Erdogan hunderttausende folgen ihnen auf
Instagram Youtube Twitter
hochprofessioneller Wahlkampf der AKP
Erdogans Partei gibt alles in Moschee
Gemeinden wird sie für ihren Shuttlebus
Service hinzu den Wahllokalen um
möglichst viele ihrer konservativen
Wähler zu mobilisieren der Journalist
Ehren gehört schien hat das Engagement
der AKP in Deutschland im Blick sie
versuchen alle möglichen Strukturen zu
mobilisieren oder zu aktivieren für ihre
für ihren Wahlkampf das sind in aller
erster Linie auch die Moschee Gemeinden
und deswegen bieten auch die AKP
Wahlkampf Teams in den unterschiedlichen
Regionen auch kostenlose Bustransfers an
was ein sehr wichtig Faktor ist gerade
für das ältere Klientel die Opposition
von der CHP hat all diese Möglichkeiten
nicht ihre Wahlbeobachter kontrollieren
dass in den Wahllokalen alles fair
bleibt und trotz der heutigen
Wahlempfehlung des Drittplatzierten
ultra-nationalisten U-Bahn für Erdogan
versuchen sie mit ihren bescheidenen
Mitteln ihre Anhängerschaft für Rollo zu
mobilisieren indem wir zum Teil auch in
unserem Bekannten Verwandten
Freundeskreis persönliche Gespräche
aufgesucht haben aber auch natürlich die
sozialen Medien hier in Anspruch
genommen haben jetzt erst recht lautet
das Motto bei unserer Wählerschaft jetzt
erst recht manche der Wählerinnen und
Wähler fahren mehr als 100 km weit um
ihre Stimme in einem Konsulat abzugeben
der Wille mitzubestimmen wer die Türkei
künftig regiert und wer nicht ist groß
in beiden Lagern
ich will mit mehreren Leuten ich habe
noch eine Familie mitgebracht ja um
ärgern zu unterstützen sind wir hier
eine Tochter habe ich mitgebracht mein
Bruder ist da mein schwiegerin Freunde
von mir sind gekommen und wir kämpfen
eben bis er geht im Großen und Ganzen
gehe ist im Wahllokal fair zu berichten
wahlbeobachte über die Urnen wacht das
Konsulat und schickt sie im Anschluss
auf eine lange Reise nach diesen fünf
Tagen waren werden die ganzen Wahlzettel
versiegelt in in Säcke versiegelt und am
nächsten Tag mit einem Flieger nach
Türkei gebracht dort werden sie dann am
Wahltag also am Wahltag in Türkei
ausgezählt bis übermorgen können Türken
und Deutsch Türken hierzulande noch
wählen im AKP Lagern zeigt man
demonstrativ dass man sich hier stark
fühlt
wenn in dieser Woche die Pfingstferien
beginnen Weg das in
Garmisch-Partenkirchen schlimme
Erinnerungen am Freitag vor Pfingsten
vor einem Jahr geschah das schwere
Zugunglück ein Regionalexpress und
Leiste auf dem Weg nach München fünf
Menschen starben dutzende wurden
verletzt die Ursache ist bis heute
ungeklärt dabei geht es natürlich auch
um Schuldfragen etwa ob es Versäumnisse
auf Seiten der Bahn gab es gar nicht
Sternberg berichtet
als eines der sichersten Reisemittel in
Deutschland gelten Züge und dennoch
geschah vor einem Jahr das
oh mein Gott wir haben das überlebt wir
haben gerade einen Zugang überlebt
wir hatten so ein Glück verhältnismäßig
hatten so ein Glück und dieses Glück
hatten halt nicht alle
Garmisch-Partenkirchen 3 juni 2022
um 12 Uhr 15 mit knapp 100 Kilometern
pro Stunde passiert ist Wagen zwei
entgleist die Lokomotive schiebt mit
immenser Kraft weiter Wagen 3 und 4
stürzen dem Bahndamm hinunter bis in den
Katzenbach
fünf Menschen darunter ein Schulkind
kommen ums Leben
noch ermittelt die Staatsanwaltschaft in
München ein offizielles Ergebnis steht
auch
Untersuchungen wurden auch von der
Deutschen Bahn durchgeführt als erste
Konsequenz kündigt sie an Betonschwellen
des Typs aus Garmisch bundesweit
auszutauschen erklärt öffentlich erste
vorläufige Erkenntnisse legen den
Verdacht nahe dass ein Herstellerfehler
vorliegt
knapp ein Jahr später Spurensuche im
Loisachtal Dieter döger ist seit Jahren
unabhängiger Sachverständiger für
Schienenverkehr er zweifelt die Version
der Bahn an hat ein Gutachten über die
Unfallursachen erstellt Auftraggeber die
Gewerkschaft deutscher Lokomotivführer
und Bürgerinitiativen der Experte
vermutet ein anderen Grund für den Bruch
der Schwellen wenn sie unten am Fuß des
Bahndammes durch bei Wegen durch diesen
Fluss hier wenn sie da Sachen wegspülen
oder der Fluss die Sachen wegspült dann
sagt das von oben irgendwann nach und
wenn das oben nachsagt dann gibt der
Schotter nach und wenn der Schotter
nachgibt dann brechen die Schwellen
direkt neben dem mutmaßlich durch
wässerten wandern verläuft der Fluss
genannt Katzenbach und die B23
in den 90er Jahren muss der Katzenbach
der Bundesstraße 23 weichen er wird
direkt neben dem bahndammt verlegt um
Platz zu machen für die Straße
die neue Route des Flusses birgt
offenbar Gefahren hätten die
planungsverantwortlichen der Deutschen
Bahn die Wasser Nähe zum Bahndamm
erkennen müssen aufgrund laufen der
Ermittlungen wolle sich die Deutsche
Bahn AG hier zu nicht konkret äußern
verweist schriftlich auf Zitat die DB
inspiziert die vorhandene Infrastruktur
regelmäßig und mögliche Schäden
frühzeitig zu erkennen und zu beheben
für Janina war es schwer in ihren Alltag
zurückzukehren die ungeklärten
Unfallursachen lassen sie sorgenvoll
zurück das ist aber jetzt doch was
anderes sein könnte
ist schon komisch also es ist gibt eine
mulmiges Gefühl sage ich mal
und die Bahn ordnet an der Unfallstelle
eine neue Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung von
70 Kilometern pro Stunde an obwohl dort
alle Betonschwellen ausgewechselt wurden
einen ausführlichen Bericht mit neuen
Recherchen dazu gibt es morgen Abend in
unserem investigativ Magazin Sonntag
und jetzt geht es bei Heiz weiter mit
Wirtschaft und da schauen wir auf den
Strom und Gasmarkt und wie sich der
aktuell die Preise entwickeln nach den
Rekordpreisen der Energiekrise ist der
inzwischen wieder einiges in Bewegung
Frank beetmann womit können oder müssen
Verbraucher rechnen zunächst mal an den
Energiemärkten fallen die Preise bereits
seit Jahresbeginn wieder einige Energie
Grundversorger haben daher angekündigt
ab Mai die Tarife zu senken laut
Berechnungen des Vergleichsportals
Verivox wird Strom demnach bei diesen
Anbietern im Durchschnitt um rund 14%
günstiger Gas um rund 23% doch wie viele
profitieren davon überhaupt
das Signal in Grenzen weil es betrifft
nur ungefähr zehn vielleicht 15% der
grundversorgungsanbieter im Bereich
Strom und Gas
grundvorsorger das sind die Unternehmen
als Stadtwerke die in einem Netzgebiet
die meisten Haushalte versorgen sie
kaufen in der Regel Strom und Gas
langfristig ein heißt aber auch das
längst nicht alle von ihnen schon wieder
von den fallenden Großhandelspreisen
profitieren bei etlichen Stadtwerken
bleiben die Beschaffungskosten hoch und
damit auch das Preisniveau laut Verivox
liegen noch immer knapp 80% aller Strom
und fast 90% aller gas-tarife in der
Grundversorgung über den Preis bremsen
die die Bürger bei den Energiekosten
entlasten sollen anders sieht das für
Neukunden aus wenn sich jetzt einen
neuen Versorger sucht dürfte nun wieder
Tarife finden die deutlich unter der
Preis Bremse liegen Frank Beckmann
vielen Dank
der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt aktuell
vor Unwetter mit schweren Gewittern
heftigem Starkregen und Hage die
Warnungen gelten für Teile Oberbayern
sind zwar westlich von München mehr zur
aktuellen Lage und zu den Aussichten
gleich im Wetterbericht
im vergangenen Jahr gab es die erste
komplett private Mission zur
Internationalen Raumstation heute hat
zum zweiten Mal eine Besatzung im Rahmen
eines privatflugs an der ISS angedockt
unter der vierköpfigen Crew befindet
sich die ehemalige NASA Astronautin
Peggy risin die ihren Rekord als Frau
mit der längsten Gesamtaufenthaltsdauer
im All weitere 10 Tage ausbauen wird
außerdem erstmals dabei eine Frau aus
Saudi-Arabien organisiert wurde die
Mission von privaten
Raumfahrtunternehmen Aktion space das
den Bau einer privaten Raumstation plant
das war von uns gleich nach dem Wetter
geht es mit dem ZDF montagskino weiter
heute mit Pierce Bros
[Musik]
guten Abend gerade hatten sich einige
über Sonnenschein und Wärme gefreut da
kam heute schon gleich das dicke Ende in
Form von kräftigen Gewittern die
höchsten Wolken haben wir für sie rot
eingefärbt denn unter diesen höchsten
Wolken verbergen sich oft kräftige
Gewitter ab 14 Uhr ging das Los vor
allen Dingen über den Mittelgebirgen
einige Zellen waren besonders heftig wie
diese hier im Sauerland da gab es 100
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter in kaum
mehr als einer Stunde und auch Hagel im
Laufe des Tages konnten sie sehr schön
sehen wie diese Wolken fast
explosionsartig in den Himmel schossen
und das hatte auch zur Folge dass diese
Gewitter sich an Ort und Stelle
Entbluten deswegen gab es diese enormen
Regenmengen einige bekamen gar nichts
davon ab z.B im Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
und auch in Teilen von Bayern da gab es
heute überhaupt keine Gewitter aber die
gute Nachricht jetzt in der am Anfang
der Nacht ist dass die meisten Gewitter
doch in sich zusammengefallen sind und
einzig südlich von München deswegen auch
die Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes ist noch ein kräftigeres
Gewitter unterwegs letzte Gewitter gibt
es allerdings noch in Deutschland sonst
immer wird das eine sehr milde Nacht mit
Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 15 und 9
Grad und morgen verlassen uns die
Gewitter und im Nordwesten wird es schon
recht freundlich sondern Wolken wechseln
sich ab in der Westhälfte gibt es nur
noch wenige Schauer der Winter hat aber
schon gedreht auf nördliche Richtungen
und so wird es deutlich kälter als
zuletzt im Westen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei 14 bis 18 im
Osten und im Süden bei 18 bis 22 Grad in
den nächsten Tagen gibt es noch Schauer
in den Alpen und auch am alten Nordrand
sonst aber wird es doch immer sonniger
bei Temperaturen zwischen 13 und 22 Grad
guten Abend